The next principle we should
talk about is automation.
Whenever you write a piece of
code to perform a task that
otherwise you do by hand,
that counts as automation.
There are a lot of steps
of both development and
operations processes
that can be automated.
One big one is deployment, setting
up a server to run an application.
Once upon a time, sysadmins would
spend a lot of time setting up
physical servers individually.
And when you needed to
install software upgrades,
you'd log into each machine and
run the upgrade.
Now smart operations people would
automate as much of this as possible,
like throw together a shell script
that logs into each server and
runs the upgrade.
But that kind of work generally
wasn't visible outside of ops.
There's something that ops did to
make their own job easier, but
it wasn't recognized as a vital
function of the organization.
But today, on the other hand, you don't
have one or two physical servers for
an application.
You might have dozens of server
instances on a cloud platform, or
you might have hundreds to support
a large and popular application.
At that scale, you can't reasonably
manage them by hand at all.
You need automation just
to get the job done.
Now on the development side of things,
there are also a bunch of
things that can be automated.
This isn't really new with DevOps.
The agile movement embraced unit
testing, acceptance testing, and
continuous integration.
But DevOps ties these into
the deployment process,
eliminating the boundary between
developer side automation and
operation side automation.
After all, if we're both
working on the same service,
why should we have two
incompatible views of it?
Well, we'll be talking more about
automation in lessons two and three,
and you'll get some hands-on experience
with automating parts of the testing and
deployment workflow.